[Musique]
ici bien les proches qui vous parle en
direct de monaco où se déroule
actuellement le 225e festival annuel du
film pornographique sous le haut
patronage s'il n'y a pas de patronne à
ces propos le film que j'ai vu pour vous
hier soir au familial ciné de monaco
s'appelle oh oui oh là là c'est bon
encore oh la la
étonnant nous tout d'abord une fois de
plus de l'indigence des traducteurs qui
baptise oh oui oh là là c'est bon encore
oh là là une oeuvre dont le titre
original est au yes olala hills good
once again
oh là là mais ne faisons pas la fine
bouche à ce détail près oh oui oh là là
c'est bon ou encore oh là là est une
oeuvre attachante à bien des égards
danser
non oui bien des égards l'ours et déjà
on peut parler de chefs-d'oeuvre qu'est
ce qui se passe voilà que cette pétarade
c'est une ville très mouvementée si le
la principauté est en guerre on sepric
l'histoire bouleversante dans sa
simplicité et claire sombrement le drame
humain de 11 sténodactylographe
magistralement interprété par les
majorettes de monaco et de 14
représentants de commerce vivent en
communauté dans un lit 240 dans le plus
complet dénuement
un matin on sonne à la porte c'est le
facteur plus précisément ce sont les
facteurs puisqu'ils sont neufs
magistralement interprété par les
compagnons de la chanson par la suite
voilà voilà qu'on sonne à la porte n'est
ce pas c'est une enquêtrice de l'ifop
ou plus précisément ce sont les
enquêtrices de l'ifop puisqu'elles sont
19 magistralement interprété par les
grandes soeurs du petit rat de l'opéra
de monaco
usant d'un style elliptique qu'il
méprisait qu'ils maîtrisent pardon à
merveille depuis glissant glissons j'ai
rarement vu quelque chose d'aussi osé
l'auteur élude volontairement une
semaine entière de l'action la seule qui
ne se passe pas dans le lit de 140
alors pourquoi alors écrit l'auteur dans
le monde d'hier je cite j'ai voulu
exprimer ainsi l'incohérence des
rapports humains en milieu libéral si je
réussis je pense avoir contribué
humblement au rapprochement une femme
si j'échoue je m'en fous je suis pas au
pourcentage sur recettes voilà c'est un
film je vous répète qui est souvent très
dures quelquefois très mou mais jamais
vulgaire et j'ai c'est au cinéma
familial ciné de monaco ici pierre
desproges à vous les studios
[Musique]